your mind here's the debate
[Music]
and we're live episode number 149 with
the great rick
massey and if you don't know who he is
if you've watched the movie king richard
king richard
went to rick massey and said you need to
come to compton to meet my kids it was
played by john bernthal which i believe
it was 225 people that
went and auditioned for
that role to play you and he was the one
that won it and some stats that you need
to know about eight grand slam champions
have been coached by him five players
ranked first place 322 usta national
championships 52 grand slam championship
wins seven time uspta coach of the year
four hall of fame inductees and in 2017
it was the youngest ever to be inducted
into the uspta hall of fame andy roddick
he coached jennifer capriati coach maria
sharapova which he may ask for a number
he coached serena williams he coached
venus williams he coached
and uh some people may be watching say
pat this is i mean what are you doing
talking tennis let me tell you why i'm
talking tennis i got four kids and my
kids play sports and my dad's obsessed
with tennis and i watch this movie and i
said dude i want to talk to this man so
thank you so much for making the time
for being on the podcast no i'm glad to
be here i'm fired up and ready to go yes
i mean right when the camera was on
adam's like turn on the camera we got to
go live he's on fire so first of all you
know for for folks uh i mean at this
point in the game most people know your
story from the movie right they know you
from the movie but
how did you get into the tennis world
how did this happen all the way down to
when the movie happened and you're
seeing yourself on the big screen what
does it feel like seeing john play you
so walk us through that story well let's
let's go back down the yellow brick road
you know when i was uh i was born in
greenville ohio a small town southwest
of dayton uh my dad died when i was 10.
we i used to play golf i was very good
in golf and there was tennis courts like
a half mile from my house i went down
there one day because we couldn't afford
to go to the country club anymore i
picked up a racquet i started hitting
the ball against the wall i really liked
it because it always came back and i was
a pretty competitive guy
um to fast forward
by 18 i was number one in the ohio
valley i got really good real quick i
played basketball uh in the hall of fame
for basketball and tennis my hometown
um
dabbled a little bit on the satellite
but i knew at a young age uh i like
helping other people more than i liked
helping myself so i got into coaching
when i was like 22.
as time went on i said if i really want
to go for this i got to go to california
or florida early 80s i went to a place
called green leaf golf and tennis resort
in haines city florida
was there for a while and then in 1985
a doctor from winterhaven florida
brought his son to me a nine-year-old
boy named tommy ho uh he held the racket
like a ping-pong paddle he had a really
funny grip but i saw a lot of potential
to fast forward that story he became the
most dominant junior tennis player ever
uh he won kalamazoo
at 15 years old as an 18 year old in
1988 the youngest uh that record still
stands today he won more gold balls and
stampers agassi chang than anybody
and from his success a guy named stefano
capriati brought jennifer to me who
lived right here in lauderhill said i
don't want to teach my daughter how to
serve she kind of served like chris
everett she was kind of a chrissy clone
which is not bad especially mentally um
jennifer
won the 18s as a 12 year old when i had
her that record still stands today
that's one to eight things at 12. that's
brutal that doesn't happen now because
psychologically i mean you got to be
like how do you
lose to a 12 year old recovered from it
mentally
you know what i'm saying yeah
a senior in high school you lose to uh
yeah she probably retired a lot of
people that had big dreams but you know
but i had the daily double in 1988 those
records still stand today so from that
um a couple years later i get a phone
call from this guy a name richard
williams and he said i have two
daughters
i heard of them in the new york times i
guess venus was undefeated in the ten
and under and he goes
really funny guy
the only thing i knew about compton was
like riots and that type of stuff and he
goes if you come to compton i promise i
won't get you shot okay and i thought
the guy was hilarious and i never go see
someone they either come to the academy
or i see him at a junior tournament
so i just figured i'll take a shot
so
obviously it's the best vacation i ever
took going to compton california so i go
to compton i flew out there one weekend
in may right before summer
and it was just like yesterday you know
they that night venus serena richard
orsine come to the hotel
venus on one leg
serena on the other
hugging kissing close-knit family just
like you see in that movie richard pulls
out a piece of paper uh he grilled me
like i was in a deposition you know i
thought like well if he wanted someone
in their circle he wanted a role model a
father figure and someone who's been
there done that so i didn't i wasn't
defensive about it i kind of respected
that he was taking the temperature so he
said we're picking you up tomorrow at
seven o'clock
that bus you see in the movie okay so at
seven o'clock they pick me up i get in
the passenger side
i get harpoon and the buttock there's a
spring sticking up i'm looking back you
got venus and serena back there there's
mcdonald's wrappers there's four months
worth of garbage there's ball hoppers it
was crazy it was like it was like i was
in a movie now remember i'm at a
five-star resort now i hear him in
compton i'm in this bus that's wobbling
around he goes we're going to east
compton hills country club so we go and
about 10 minutes into the ride
i'm looking around and i'm going this is
a strange place for a country club we
pull up to a park
we get out there's about 20 guys
shooting hoops there's people smoking
there's people drinking there's people
passed out we get out now listen to this
it's 1991
all right
they go hey richard
hey king richard
they called the guy king then we had to
go across because they knew who he was
and they knew who the girls were they go
hey vw hey meek serena's middle name is
serena jamica williams so we go across
the basketball court it parts like the
red sea like these kids are celebrity
and they're two little hamburgers at
nine and ten years old you know so we go
across the basketball court onto the
court i had a box of wilson balls
shipped there and he goes rick
we don't use new balls i want old balls
i want him digging i want him ben you
know digging out the balls i got it it
was a little different so now we go on
to the tennis court me and you wouldn't
even play on the court okay there was a
shopping cart
attached to the net post the same
shopping cart you see in that in the
movie
richard had like seven chains wrapped
around it he looks at me goes rick i
gotta secure it it won't be here in the
morning so it took him 20 minutes to get
the cart ready puts the old balls in so
i start drilling venus and serena now
remember i had jennifer capriati now she
was already 14 top 10 in the world she
was already on the pro tour so my
blueprint for greatness was probably
more than anybody in the world yeah
so she had her racket back in the
parking lots low center of gravity great
fundamentals by the late great jimmy
ever so now i'm out there with venus and
serena
arms legs hair beads flying off their
head i'm going what in god's name am i
doing in compton california there were
maybe 70 80 in the nation which i see
that all the time
so
after about an hour
it's a great lesson for anybody any
parent coach or rick macy okay you don't
judge a book by the cover the cover
could be terrible the book amazing okay
the cover amazing the book great so you
got to understand now i said let's play
competitive points
and the whole landscape changed when i
said game on
the footwork got better they were
popping the popcorn extra butter the
preparation got better
the burning desire
there was there was a rage inside these
two little girls the burning desire
to get to the ball
was brutal wow now listen i have listen
i've told so many people and i have a
lot of kids that try hard this was
different there was something inside of
them even though it was a train wreck on
the outside
and when i saw they ran so hard and now
i'm projecting in my head
5 10
145
6 feet a buck 60 and i'm thinking where
this is gonna go and i right then and
there i richard come here and this is in
the movie i said and it was more about
venus because she was a little more
mature serena was like a little
prankster she was nine
i go
you got the next female michael jordan
on your hand and he puts his arm around
me he goes no brother man i got the next
two that's and i've seen it no no and so
but wait so then
venus goes daddy can i go the bathroom
okay they're hugging kissing close-knit
family just like you see in the movie
okay they were just like bang they were
like that
venus goes out the gate
walks on her hands
for five feet does backward cartwheels
for five feet and then i'm going whoa
whoa whoa so remember this was 1991.
if you were big and strong in women's
tennis you weren't really nimble so now
i'm thinking not only can these kids be
number one in the world
with the right coaching and financial
back
they can they can change everything
because they can transcend the sport
they were going to bring a different act
i knew this when you saw that
but i didn't but the moral of the story
yeah okay the moral of the story is
i didn't see it on the outside it's what
i saw on the inside
why i took the chance
all the sweat equity millions of dollars
and i rolled the dice because everybody
thought i was crazy and i get that
question a lot now why would i do it
that's what i tell people all the time
what you may see is very different than
rick macy
what you may see is very different than
what rick may seem
you said you had to invest millions of
dollars is that what you just said yeah
no yeah listen um
i probably put
four to five hours a day of me
one-on-one there was hitting partners
ballet boxing taekwondo uh disney
tickets you know a house ninety two
thousand dollar motor home so you gotta
understand i took on the whole family
you were funding all that you're saying
yeah you know i'm not img i'm not a
billion dollar corporation but i
believed in
a couple things i believed in venus
serena
richard and most of all myself whether
this took
four years eight years
i knew this was different you gotta
remember i had capriati and i i just
knew
but i knew a lot of work had to be done
you know technically but at the end of
the day
everybody wants to know now especially
after the movie why did i take a chance
because i had to take the i had to take
the whole family and move them here so
but it wasn't a risk because
my mom always told me if you're going to
bet bet on one thing yourself and i
don't bet and the only thing i really
ever bet on was venus and serena and the
best trip i ever made in my life was
going to compton california
what role did the mother play
huge okay she was silent
but deadly when she spoke okay uh she
got everybody's attention so she wasn't
as involved like on the court and stuff
like that but off the court um you got
to remember
the reason why
venus and serena
they they were like my own daughters and
richard was my best friend and even
though if you see the movie so stubborn
and i'm i tell people i should be in the
hall of fame just putting up with that
guy for four years you know i mean it
was it but it was because
a world-class dad okay the life lessons
that he taught these kids and the mother
every single night and i don't see that
nowadays every single night after the
lessons after the training whether it's
good bad happy or sad rick thank you
very much
crazy and every day they brought their
books to the court if it rained go to
rick's office and study these are the
things that people don't know so what he
did as a father
every day okay he was taking these girls
home at night at 10 and 11.
you got to make sure you have the goods
if you go this he was like out there
he would interview them
on a on it put up his tripod he'd be
asking him questions at 10 and 11
preparing them for the future of how to
answer the question without answering
the question because remember you're two
little african-american girls going in a
predominantly white sport and people are
saying you're legendary yeah then you
got rick macy's saying you're gonna be
better than capriati so this took
nuclear proportions because we're
talking nbc abc
this was they got more press than people
number one in the world on the pro tour
before it even happened
okay and he
but that started at birth
that was baked in extra crispy how
mentally strong they were before i met
him but he was teaching them life
lessons all the time and left the heavy
lifting to me now let me ask you this so
so during that time when everything's
going on and then the movie comes out
and then when the movie comes out you
see what happens with will smith winning
the academy and all that stuff that
takes place with the slapping and then
you said something off camera about
about will if you're comfortable sharing
give give me the perspective from the
movie coming out
to then will winning oscar to then the
incident that took place what did that
do to the whole story well first off
that's a great question when i went to
the red carpet and the after party and i
met will and it was it was kind of
interesting he was more excited to meet
me than me to meet him it was kind of a
weird dynamic because you got to
remember when you're a character and
you're into someone that deep okay and i
i didn't really understand that because
that's not my world okay um
no one had a better front row seat than
rick macy other than maybe the wife
because i was there every day
five hours a day six days a week that
doesn't sound like a lot but you go 365
days a year for four years there's a lot
of crap that could go on and blow the
whole thing up so i'm there every day
and that's why that's why i love richard
even though he was out there on a lot of
stuff so
will got so into the character when i
saw the movie when we had the screening
and voca
it blew me away the the subtleties the
nuances the walk the talk the the
idiosyncrasies it took him two hours
just to put on how he had to look like
richard
it
it was beyond richard and this is what
i've told other people when i spoke to
him so and you gotta remember this
happened during the pandemic so
this guy was probably going into this
shopping mall he was probably going home
talking to his kids like that he became
richard and there was one
scene in the movie where uh it was in my
office in 1994
before venus was going to make her debut
all right
and i don't know it's day one or some tv
show and the guy asked venus
do you think you can win
and venus goes i know i can and then the
guy pressed her you say that so
confidently and venus goes i am
confident
and then she the guy goes why are you
confident
and she she goes because i am and then
richard blew a gasket he comes running
onto the set okay and just tortures the
guy and i'm sitting here going oh my god
what do you mean did he assault him no
no no no he didn't assault him but he
got that far from his face he got up in
his grill got his grill just said listen
leave her alone she's a little you know
a little black girl you know
your your ass is going to be in the
ground you know she he just he blew a
gasket richard was so protective
of those girls okay
and will even made reference of that
when he saw that
in 94. it will brought that up but i'm
sure that was discussed a lot during the
movie so now
you go through the movie and the minute
i saw it i've told other people he's
going to win an oscar even though i
don't know how that stuff works in my
opinion he was going to get an oscar
so now
when he's at the oscar
that reaction was beyond bizarre that
doesn't mean
i'm justifying it but something inside
of him
made him do that because looking back
i'm sure he wished he wouldn't have done
it because the ripple's worse than now
the action but
maybe the guy thought he was richard
williams so that's very very that's my
take on it it doesn't justify he has to
own it but at the end of the day uh it
was bizarre
when he did that when when he got up on
stage i know not that you're a you know
psychiatrist or doctor or anything like
that but you have a front row seat to
all this right yeah richard williams
venus serena will smith you're i saw you
on the red carpet with john bernthal
when he went up there and slapped chris
rock
what percentage of that was he was in
the richard williams character moment
still in it
and then what percentage was the
everything that's been he's been dealing
with in his own personal life with jada
is it a cumulative effect
i mean you said that he was basically
becoming this guy richard williams
what's your analysis
yeah you know i another great question i
think a lot of it is is richard because
initially he laughed
i just think that he wasn't even
thinking i mean it was just
richard i know it's hard for people on
the outside to look at like that you
know but they become these people and uh
he even kind of said that when he was
given his speech
the crazy father and but people aren't
going to say you know that's justified
but i could see that because that was
out of character to do something like
that
at that moment
when he's at the pinnacle because he's
done a lot of great things in movies
what do you think pat well you ever seen
the the moment when the
jack nicholson's having dinner
uh jack nicholas which one's the actor
jack nicholson jack nicholson's having
dinner okay
he comes out of a restaurant and a
reporter comes up and he says hey jack
did you hear about what happened to
heath ledger what happened to him
he just he was found dead
he says what
he says yes do you remember what his
next line is no because they were both a
joker he says i told him never to play
joker [ __ ] you never seen this i got i
recall it yes he says i told him to
never play the joker now
there's a part of that on what you're
saying that i can agree with because if
you're playing a role that long for that
much i can see how you can take a method
actors yeah yeah i can see how you can
take that and become that like you know
they say daniel day-lewis is one of the
greatest actors of all time because of
the way even uh what's his name talked
about it ethan so please talked about it
last week
where you know he gets into it so much
yeah that's like he's just a fully a
part of it right and you just you don't
even know who you are you leave daniel
day lewis when he played the last set of
mohicans you know he went out there and
lived out there to know what he gets in
it oh he gets in when he was the butcher
and yeah
or five towns well maybe he should have
skipped the uh maybe will should have
skipped going to the oscars that day
because that's slap change but one more
point you know it's different like if
you're
in a movie and you're an actor that's
one thing but remember he was playing
a person this a bio that's that's a
little different than just acting yeah
you know what i'm saying i mean he was
an alive person too there is a
difference
there are zero excuses for his behavior
zero except now
there's no way you know that's kind of
like
saying a professional athlete who is
super super super competitive goes and
slaps like latrell spreeville of spring
what he did to his coach i don't
remember that when he coached his show
choked his coach
and uh you know or some of the other
stories you hear about uh rudy tom
janovich years ago running the other guy
knocks him in you remember the whole
center of court yeah yeah center court
so there's no exception larry bird who
did that no not larry bird larry bird
got it maybe that was doctor james
exactly a few times where moses was
holding him back but that's completely
different but do you think the backlash
against will is actually justified to
the point where what he did was that bad
yes we agreed not a good thing to do
yeah but he didn't beat the crap out of
somebody he didn't murder somebody he
slapped another man
so you know they're telling his will
will's getting canceled
never again it's like this was the like
the the biggest just hollywood
blockbuster star out there i get it but
do you think it's overblown it's a
culmination i don't think it's just one
thing i think it's a combination of a
lot of different things he's dealing
with i think it's 50 80 percent of stuff
that we don't know about and it's 20 of
stuff that we know about the 80 percent
of stuff that we don't know about it
we're all speculating you know just what
we did a couple days ago with the whole
shirt free will yeah the campaign that
we put together that uh uh but anyway
it's going back to this week you know
what it is by the way what there's
certain things that we may see and
there's certain things that rick made
yeah that's right well i think it's a no
i it's a good one uh i should use that i
think it's a medley of stuff if he'd
have done that
on the street it's no big deal but
because he did it in that backdrop yes
and
you know they they have to do something
even if it's just to do something that's
what that's what's bad about the whole
thing they just have to react they can't
just say don't worry about it bro you
know it's okay uh state they had to do
something it's kind of like the johnny
depp story right you know the johnny
depp story that's going through
uh
you know with uh what's the amber ride
that they're going through i don't know
if you're following the story or not
with the two of them that they're well
he's hollywood these days he's on the
red carpet how could he not no i'm on
the court i'm i'm going to stay on the
court yeah that's my wheelhouse but but
this whole story that's going on and all
these videos becoming uh what do you
call it all these videos becoming like
the recordings that they're talking
about and you know everything is public
i don't know
i don't even like the fact that so so
you guys chose to do the epstein case
and you did that private but you're
doing this public like it should be the
other way around that one affected
people's lives this is between two
people leave them alone and they're
getting embarrassed publicly and the
recording you're you're hearing about
you don't know what people are really
dealing with johnny depp one guy said
something he said uh in the last 50
years there's not one story of johnny
ever raising his hands on anybody right
meaning
will smith the last i don't know 30
years there's not one story of will
doing what he just did and will's played
a lot of different roles he played ali
he beat the [ __ ] out of people and he
literally could have come out and said
well i felt like i was ali for a minute
and i did yeah so but the point is going
there has to be he's going through a lot
so that's a completely different
conversation but let me come back to you
with with king richard and the coaching
so uh you know i rented out a
room in at the breakers hotel okay which
you know where breakers at it's at the
palm beach area and i do meetings all
the time but one of the meetings i heard
last year which was in july did you go
to this one or nowhere well we watched
uh nick boleteri's documentary i don't
know if you've seen that one on netflix
or not if you haven't seen it it's a
pretty
solid uh documentary now this guy is a
guy that i knew of but i didn't know him
know him because i'm not in the tennis
world i didn't follow tennis you know
but i watched the documentary and i said
huh
so pretty epic personality i think he
says yeah i've been married seven or
eight times i lost count how many times
i've been married and you know his style
was all psychological and you know the
way he would you know coach people and
pin them against each other and play
games and sit on the other side with
courier while sit on this side and all
of these games he played with his style
of coaching versus yours you guys are
not far from each other you're 30 40
miles away from each other when he was
uh coming up and i don't know we i think
he's in miami right is he in miami or is
he bradington okay bradington south
florida and which is what like 40 miles
give or take i don't know about three
and a half hours
no he's on the way he's on the west why
did i think he's down here he used to be
but now he's at home no he started it
yeah he started
in miami long ago but he went to
bradington
he's been all over here what is the
style of coaching because conversations
will come up who's the greatest tennis
coaches of all time and he has a stuff
that's put up put out there your name
comes up brad gilbert's name comes a lot
of names comes up right this is the part
of the competitiveness that we like to
talk about how different is your style
of coaching versus his style of coaching
um
well i'm very different than
everybody i'm just cut from a different
cloth
i tell people all the time you know my
favorite student of all time who's ever
on the other side of the net that hour
that minute that second
my name's on the door but i still teach
50 hours a week whether it's to you your
son the number one 80 year old guy in
the country or someone top 10 in the
world so i'm on the court all the time
there's no big machine behind me like
marketing and pushing this thing and
trying to
become there might be people more famous
but you know let's just stack up kind of
the resumes and just line up and see
where everything is and really who
you've worked with but what i do is a
little different it's like a medley or a
smorgasbord of everything in one hour
there's going to be a lot of mental
training there's going to be a lot of
tactical strategical there's dealing
with the parents it's putting humpty
dumpty together and how i do this and
the art of communication okay of how i
do this i've been on a tennis court
since age 22 more than anybody in the
world
and i'm still that's my living room you
know and so what i do is very very
different and i connect with people and
i can extract greatness out of people
how do you do that well i gotta find
them with but what buttons to push maybe
what buttons i push with you are going
to be different i get people to believe
okay but it's it's a it's a it's a
package like anybody who's great it's
not just one thing okay it's a it's a
combination of a lot of things and so
how i talk to an eight-year-old girl is
going to be different than a 20 year old
guy and how i put this together to
motivate and get them to think big and
stay in touch with them uh whether it be
an emoji or a gift there's there's just
this constant
getting stuff out of people and you know
the best reward is not all those people
you mentioned who became number one or
people that won grand slams
i mean since 85 there's over 322 usda
national titles okay that that's that's
a lot it's the people who maybe clean
the room better or get better grades or
they're not on drugs or they come back
and they say the work ethic and these
things they've learned from rick macy so
it's a it's more the ripple effect but
what's great about this i don't try to
do that that's just part of the coaching
i don't need to pick up a chair and
throw it at the person like bobby knight
okay i i know when to hug him okay i
know when to kick him in the butt
there's an art to this and that's why
the birthday what month's your birthday
december 7th 1954 december 7th got it
and i saw online you had three daughters
do any one of them play
tennis or no
they did at a young age that's another
great question i because they're all
very athletic okay and when they were
like eight six and five i took them to
tennis court and it's like 110 degrees
and we ran laps around the court and
they went right out the gate to the
drinking fountain i said okay gymnastics
we're going to the air conditioning
listen this is a brutal sport and i said
listen you i'm a type of guy either in
or out either go for the jugular or we
don't do this and two of them were
undefeated in gymnastics by the way and
listen they're all healthy happy and i
raised all three of them by myself at
age thirteen so just for that i should
be in the hall of fame raise them all by
yourself from age 13 all three besides
working the crazy amount of hours so but
it's helped me also
how i deal with
other people it's been just another part
of you know your maturation just out of
curiosity how many times have you been
married twice twice okay so nick's got
you beaten in a modern time being
married yeah he's only though only
reason i ask this question is the
following reason i'm in the army i'm
about to go into special forces okay
so 18 delta i'm going to fifth group i
love it my captain my colonel lieutenant
colonel peacock's got all the orders i
wanted everything i wanted he got me i
want to go to vacenza italy
i'm going to go to the they're telling
me to dli because i speak four or five
languages i'm going to go to sears i'm
going to go to
and then he says but before i become
special forces i need you to go and
interview with five special forces three
or five special forces guys to interview
with and i want to start to talk himself
tell me about their life what is three
special forces what does it be social
forces yeah says well uh you ever want
to have kids yeah you ever want to have
family yeah you ever want to get married
and stay married for a long time yeah
never join special forces why because
this is your wife your kids your
personal life
everything
you have to give everything to this to
make it
at this level right
do you think there's an element of that
in the world of what you guys do because
you're dealing with the kids you're
dealing with the parents you're dealing
with the athletes you're dealing with
trying to build a business you're
dealing with guys you and nick were
going back and forth with capriati
recruiting and he's recruiting your guy
you're you're recruiting his guy's like
well now he's but i never try to recruit
their venus well i never try to recruit
capta this competitiveness that happens
because that's part of i'm in business
and that happens all the time right yeah
it's annoying it's frustrating it's
challenging do you think eventually it
gets to the point that you say you know
what uh
i'm going to retire from the marriage
side and i'm just going to give my life
to a
tennis and that's the game i'm going to
play am i reading it correctly i'm
completely off no you're you're you're
in the game okay um i've been i haven't
been married since 2000 so now it's 2022
you know and you know i work seven days
a week you know and i open up the park
every morning and uh i'm just all in
because i answer everybody's call
everybody's email even though there's 10
other guys that work for me and four
fitness trainers and you know i just
everything in life you have to be happy
and you got to do what works for you and
what works for me
um you're right because i don't if i'm
on the phone i don't want someone to say
you got to get off yeah or don't answer
the phone okay or you know
this this because you got to remember
the way i do it because i control my
model is different i have a different
model my academy than anybody in the
world i drive that engine okay because
i'm on the court all the time we're not
a glorified boarding school like img and
bradington that's about marketing that's
about volume everybody has cords palm
trees sunshine or whatever but just like
you saw in the movie
if you have potential
and you want to dive in and you want
rick okay i'll help you and that's
that's a big thing who's delivering the
goods for your kids so your so your
offer is
you're going to get more hands-on from
me than if you go to a different place
you're going to get it from the coaches
who report to the coaches who report to
the coaches you're going to get the copy
of the copy the copies that kind of what
you're saying that's what's different
with you than others absolutely and
that's that's that's why
uh that's why the model works i mean i
drive that engine because people you
know they obviously look at the track
record you know been there done that but
i'm just like i'm just one of the guys
i'm so down to earth and you know
genuine about this whole stuff um i
always keep my eye on the ball and like
i said i i treat everybody exactly the
same it doesn't matter if they're top 10
in the world or they just uh want a
lesson and they're five years old you
said you said you want people to be all
in or else like your daughters well
right after the tennis practice 110 they
go drink water you're like nope you're
going to go gymnastics that's what
you're going to do and they both couple
them are undefeated but go back to you
said i said what's your style of
coaching you said button i know how to
push buttons well may work for you and i
work with this person
okay great i totally get it give me
i can come up with 20 different buttons
i've ran a sales team for the last 20
something years we have licensed 35 000
insurance agents and we have 20 000
insurance agents and to drive them
you're right it's very different
what's going to move her is not going to
be what moves him it's not going to be
what moves them everyone's different
from your lens
making it at the point zero zero zero
one percent of your world yeah that
you're in
how many different buttons are there
give me a few of them
well okay let's just go back to venus
and serena because i knew i knew what i
had sure every time i talked to them and
say they hit a certain shot i would say
something like this that was good but
hingis is going to get that that was
good but capriati's going to get that or
steffi graf so here i am talking to 11
year old even though it was a
world-class shot
our eye was on
a bunch different situation and like
venus always says he was rick i was
almost brainwashed to be number one you
know it's a different way to communicate
with them you know even when you miss
it's a positive error because what i
teach more than anything is courage okay
i teach people to pull the trigger i
know how to even because most people
have people try not to miss
okay and you're just going to be a nice
little college player okay and if you
look at especially a lot of the girls
i've trained they all play kind of
similar they cut the court they take the
ball early they're fearless they attack
they swarm biomechanically they're put
together a little bit different okay
so
that would be one thing right off the
bat just the way i explain it it's a
positive error listen
two more inches 10 more pounds you get
to the ball
you set your set and you're smiling
that's going to be a winner you miss
that because you're 11. you know i i got
this and then i feel you know kind of
where the kids at if they need a little
bit more or i gotta be stronger you know
with them i just feel the temperature so
give me an example stronger
okay i make kids run for every ball i
tell them the fences are out in palm
beach county i don't care if the ball's
out you know one time venus
i told er i terror by this but you run
for every ball just because the ball's
out anybody can put their finger up and
call out you run for every ball even if
it's 10 feet out because someday
somewhere somebody is gonna
put you in that position
and if your brain has been there i've
i've been there that neighborhood i'm
gonna feel comfortable okay and one time
i told this to venus and i had to keep
telling her about it so richard goes
well if you don't want to run i'm out of
here so you can just run home so you
made him run home 10 miles yeah i
remember that when you say you have to
run after every ball and i played tennis
and i played football and i remember
there was a in football you'd have to
when you used to run routes you would
catch the ball turn and you would run
upfield
and and i would always be like well i
have to run 40 more yards i'm like you
know and in tennis you know if a ball is
clearly going out if you want to kind of
save your breath you know you'll let it
go out are you saying that you would
make them run to the end of the court
even though they knew it was out what's
the advantage of that no i try to get
them okay it's the ability to improvise
you know there's a fine line between
great and good great can hit clutch
shots when they're off balance and
improvise and i i'm actually
developing inner qualities dry
persistence but
run for every ball see a lot of the kids
are glad just because it went out yeah
like you know what i mean so if it's
four feet out i make them run for the
ball try to figure out how to improvise
plus they're relaxed they feel no
pressure and then they can they can
practice a shot and so that's always
been a staple um of the training because
i said if you want to be different you
got to train different and
if they don't listen to me they're
probably not going to listen to a lot of
people so that's just one little snippet
but i get people to do things
because i'm always about okay i get the
ingredients okay i put it in the oven i
bake it and then i put the icing on it
when i have a 12 year old i'm already
projecting how they're going to play at
18. and i'm playing for 18 i'm not
developing a 12 year old game that's why
i've had more kids become number one in
the nation at 12 they come to me at
seven or eight bang they're number one
in the nation not that that means any
things that doesn't mean you're gonna be
top ten but i knew it was sharapova i
knew with jennifer i a lot i can just
i didn't know with roddick even though
he was uh had a lot of competitive
things i like
men's tennis is different total
different physicality the girls is a
little easier but at the end of the day
this is kind of how i do the teaching
and probably the best compliment i
certify coaches they come from all
around the world
and they're on the court with me
four five hours a day three four hours i
mean three or four days yeah and they
watch me teach
and they ask questions and they video
and even if these people played on the
tour
okay
they're all blown away because they have
no idea you just don't read a book and
say here's how to coach they don't even
have any idea about how to deal with the
parents how to motivate the kid they
didn't realize there was this cafeteria
of stuff and this is what happened what
he said about um
men and women's tennis is different i
would just wrote it down i just wrote it
down here but i want to i want to stay
on this we'll come back to this with the
men and men and women matter of fact
let's just address it right now since
you brought it up
you know there was an interview i saw
where serena's with jimmy kimmel i think
it's kimmel i don't think it's found i
think it's kimmel and well you know you
think you can get out there and compete
with man he's like no no no i just want
to compete with says you don't
understand uh for me to go up against
andy murray there's no way i can compete
against andy murray you know it's a very
different game the muscles are different
and she just unpacks it for
jimmy and jimmy's kind of like not
wanting to hear that message because
jimmy wants to say you know
women can go out and compete with men
for somebody who's coached both sides
you know do what do you think about what
serena said do you agree with her that
it's very very different to have a woman
compete against them actually because
she said it was a different sport
the weight she said i would lose six or
if you want to put the story up john i
would lose 6060 in five minutes they
told a
i don't know what article i was reading
that said one of the
uh not professional the amateur ranking
that they have they said 450th place of
amateur ranking for men's would be the
women's number one some weird number
like that do you agree with that or do
you have this came at the height of the
thomas william thomas swimming debate
yeah
whatever number
he was and then became number one in the
world anyway tennis tennis is you know
that's kind of tricky but i agree 100
with serena she's right and you go look
when she's saying it she's coming from
fact she you know it wouldn't be five
minutes it would be longer than that and
she might scrape a game or two if she
popped a few serves into the corner but
it's just more physical the guys cover
more real estate on the court because
they're just bigger and stronger it
doesn't mean the
the girls wouldn't participate you would
have four eight maybe some ten ball
rallies but it'd be
a slow death to the end then bang you
know it's in the serves i mean come on
eight yeah
i mean no pelk these guys are hitting
140. so
what do the women serve tops
they can go into the 120 but the guys
are let's say at the corner it's coming
back it's just you're talking 140 versus
120 max yeah but it's not even the serve
i mean you still got to get it in and
you're only serving half the match so
it's and it's just it's i don't want to
say it's a different sport because
listen the women are amazing the guys
just cover more real estate you don't
realize it because both guys are
covering the real estate
you know it's a it's like a a good high
school guy bringing the ball up in the
nba dribbling the ball if the guy wanted
to he could steal it from him every time
but you don't see that in the nba
because other guys this is good here's
what's crazy about this though here's
what's great you know how sometimes
they'll say wow women don't make enough
the same amount of money as men doing
soccer you know how that conversation oh
women basketball doesn't make as much
money as nba players i'm completely okay
watching women's tennis maybe more than
men's tennis it's so weird it's not the
interest is there because it's still
competitive and yes serena and venus and
these girls are making a lot of money
they're making millions on top of
millions of dollars of money the dollar
is not that big of a difference for the
comparable to the eyeballs that they're
getting versus in basketball how many
people are watching wnba or watching you
know this is a story title just pulled
up if you want to put it up fc dallas
under 15 boys squad beat the us women's
national team in a scrimmage i mean he
says in soccer this isn't soccer yeah
this is when you kind of see
that there's certain sports it doesn't
uh
it doesn't help anyways i saw serena
talk about well let's go back to let's
go back to the coaching style so your
coaching style would you say
uh uh did you did you mirror any other
coaches from other sports
like are you a john wooden guy could you
sound like a john wooden guy um a few
other people have said that not
not really you know i i think growing up
in the midwest and you know just how i
was brought up from my mom and just
you know it's from the heart you gain
the knowledge as you go down the yellow
brick road you know and you always got
to want to continue your education but
the ability to educate motivate you know
it's it's it's that and so i really
never the biggest influence would be
probably dr jim lehrer who was the
number one sports psychologist that we
spent some time together in the early
80s he was a pioneer and now there's
many guys out there but he was the first
of the mohicans in my opinion he was a
pioneer so and i was always intrigued
with the mental part that's how i became
kind of
good in my own little bubble uh of not
having a lesson didn't he write a book
or something he's running about 20 yeah
but he had that one book that was mental
toughness training oh that was the first
this guy's a legend by the way no no jim
cyclone best friend have you read any of
this guy's books i'm not familiar with
it's insane if you pull up anyway so
yeah so he so yeah
yeah so you know and we used to play all
the time yeah you know when this was
early 80s at green leaf so that would be
really the only person i never you know
you get the knowledge as you go on and
it's just
your love and concern for the person and
you know when you see the movie you know
it comes across loud and clear how
bernthal played me even though even
though his mustache looked like a
shrubbery i had this little piece of
astroturf it took me 30 years to grow um
you could see how much i cared for the
girls and that richard was my best
friend and we were just on a mission and
when you
when your students feel that that you
would do anything you can get them to
jump over mountains and everybody feels
that way
when i'm on the court with them it
doesn't matter just the way i'm wired
that's all you know
i think there is
different levels of coaches for
different times meaning you know how
nick saban tried to go to nfl and he
wasn't a good coach not that he wasn't a
good coach he didn't win and then he
went back to college he crushed it right
calipari went to the nba with the nets i
believe
yeah and then he went back to college
and he crushed it right patino patino by
the way celtics the but but the one that
worked was uh
pete carroll
went to college to nfl back to college
back to nfl and then
you know he did very well and pete
carroll was more like come on we can do
it you know he's like more like a player
he's more like yeah but bill belichick
is not like that that's not bill
belichick that's not a style
do you think uh there is uh
styles of coaching that work at a
certain age with a kid that maybe
if let's just say if i'm trying to
develop my kids confidence maybe they
would do better with a style of a coach
like yours or wouldn't that someone's
going to give them confidence and then
when it goes into the pros like hey
listen man here's how this thing works
here's how it's going to be and then
someone's going to be kicking their
asses to challenge them and realize
here's what we have to do and i
understand there's still the
relationship part come will cook for you
let's have a good time you know you need
to know that i trust you you need to
know that i believe in you but the level
of intensity goes slightly higher as the
levels increase and the age increases
would you agree with that
kinda you know it's it depends on the
person it's so individual you know you
just can't
it's not one size fits all it's because
you're dealing with different people now
tennis it's one on one football there's
a whole cast of characters just like the
nba you know what i mean you can see the
brooklyn nets i mean they're they're
saying you know get rid of nash i mean
we don't need a coach that's kind of
what they thought but the nba comes down
to like at the final few minutes and
there's strategic things that a coach
can come in but i also i need to chime
in here i think the coaching when you
said i went to the nfl then the college
whatever
you got to look at the team also i mean
you know the quarterback and you got to
look at the players and then even when i
you asked me the question uh when about
like venus serena caprati roddick
muskina pierce sonia kennen okay all
these people that i coach
um i helped them enormously
but i feel i helped so many other people
a lot more okay because to win the derby
you got to have the horse you're not
going to do it with a donkey i can make
the donkey have great mechanics but it's
still a donkey yeah okay so you got to
remember
you got to remember
the coaching that it kind of goes both
ways i mean i don't think it'd be
difficult you know right now for
somebody to start coaching nadal
okay i mean it's already you got to
understand or each even when when
patrick started coaching uh serena
nothing against patrick okay but she
already had like 15 grand slams i mean
you just can't screw it up okay so
that
putting this thing together okay the the
the cards you're dealt with at a young
age in a lot of ways even from your
family
it's a it's it's more complex and just
saying you need someone to kick your
butt when you're older because you got
to know how to deal with that person and
even in the mba
you know what i mean they treat people
different you don't think people the
coaches of the lakers treat lebron
differently i mean come on you gotta
understand if you want to get supposed
from fire when he's in miami yeah so
it's it's a tricky thing lebron anytime
they start losing he wants the coaching
yeah you know it's
silly yeah it's silly he's been like
that for a long time and that's become a
habit with a lot of people well he's the
goat yeah other than mj
who
lebron doesn't defeat the term of the
the purpose of the word goat the
greatest of all time you can't be the
greatest of all time i mean arguably
can i ask a question because you know
we're doing it we're talking a lot about
coaching and what it takes to be a great
coach and your technique i actually want
to flip it because pat had mentioned
he's got four kids
three of them are actually starting to
do
sports right i mean tico's a little bit
but dylan for sure sena i believe as
well gymnastics right
um and all my friends
all their
kids are starting to become you know six
eight ten twelve they're
they're you know
they got kids in sports
my relationship i used to be i was a
sick athlete miami football basketball i
had the worst relationship with my dad
he was the most overbearing like at
every game yelling talking [ __ ] yelling
at me i'm yelling at him i mean you
dealt with richard williams what does it
take to be a good
parent to our sportsman to our sports
girl right it's like what what are the
qualifications that you see that the
parent needs to have for their kid to be
successful well first off first off
another great question you know they
they have to be more of a
psychologist
than a coach that's number one remember
they're always going to look at you like
dad or mom and it's very different how
you have that relationship with a boy
and a girl because with a girl the dad's
always more involved because it's
daddy's little girl they're more
protective you know besides richard
williams capriati jim pierce i've had
some of the you know fathers from you
know outer space or whatever so these
guys were all in but you got to remember
at 18
or they get a boyfriend or they get
their driver's license you could be
toast so you got to be real careful it
creates divorce it creates problems you
got to be real careful with this but on
the other hand you got to know how to
push them but you got to support them
you got to try to make them the best
athlete you can you got to instill
confidence in them you got to get them
to believe you don't know what's inside
a young child nobody does i got a better
feel than most people and that's why
i've had people move mountains and they
never thought they could do this or that
they get a full ride to ucla or georgia
or they end up you know 50 in the world
someday they never thought they could do
that to their parents and so
that would be the role of the parent but
it's it's a problem because they're all
in they're on the fence like little
league baseball they're they're
psychotic you know they can't wait to
the weekend it's a super bowl remember
yeah that's them playing that's not even
their kid they're like will smith and
richard you know they're they're them
it's their kid and
i had this with greg olsen he played for
the panthers and when he did his podcast
yeah he's in he does this youth sports
thing and he goes rick i think i'm
becoming one of them and he's been there
done that you know he's an nfl pro
bowler and you got to understand
it's your kid right and you gotta make
sure you can separate it because it
it can burn the kid out you gotta
motivate listen the snow one died
you know the sun's gonna come out to up
tomorrow
it's about the process of getting better
and i tell our body if you're not
getting better you're getting worse it's
not where you start it's where you
finish this is a long-term process
what's the goal get the best college
scholarship the grades are important
just keep getting better you got to get
better but it's hard to do that because
it's all about winning because people
come up how'd you do i lost i won you
want to talk about the cocktail party i
get all that stuff but it's it's a
journey and that's what i loved about
richard williams when he said we're not
playing any junior tournaments and this
is in the movie
in the movie it kind of had me freaked
out like wait a minute you didn't tell
me that in compton i was okay with not
playing because venus and shrina would
run over broken glass to get to a ball
and then they'd run back over to get the
next one they were so competitive if
there's a piece of bread on the table
they'd fight to get it so i i they
didn't need to compete to learn how to
win and lose so i knew on monday we
weren't dealing with a junior tournament
why'd you lose we're just developing now
but i'm not so stuck in my way as a
coach as you mentioned
hey i coach venus serena they didn't
play any junior tournaments here's the
blueprint shut it down
no i'm not like that okay i i gotta feel
the temperature some need to play more
some less but no that's a great question
by the way breaking news elon musk
officially about twitter okay oh damn
twitteringlaw must strike a deal for
takeover it's a done deal let's read the
story can it go up so you can zoom in i
can read that title go up a little bit
go up a little bit go up a little bit
zoom in control plus control plus
uh
okay so let's see right there twittering
on monday accepted elon musk to take
over the company given
the world's richest man controlled
influential social media network where
he is also among its powerful users the
deal marks the close of a dramatic court
trip courtship and a sharp change of
heart at twitter where many executives
and board members initially pose musk's
takeover approach the deal has polarized
twitter's employees and users and
regulators over the power tech giant
wheeled in determining the parameters of
acceptable discourse on the internet and
how companies enforce their rules the
two sides worked through the night to
hash out a deal earlier on monday the
wall street journal reported twitter mr
moss reached an agreement to value
twitter at 44 billion dollars a takeover
if it goes through would mark one of the
biggest acquisitions in tech history and
will likely be have
global repercussions for years to come
related to how billions of people use
social media musk who is also the ceo of
tesla and space exploration technology
must find a way
to balance this commitment less
moderation with the business needs of a
company that has struggled to reconcile
free willing conversations with content
that appeals to advertise on monday uh
after the journal reported that a deal
was closed mr musk indicated tweeted to
indicate that he wants the platform to
remain destination for wide-ranging
discourse and
the disagreement i hope that even my
worst critics remain on twitter because
that is what free speech is all about so
five step on what this guy's gonna do
move number one he bought twitter move
number two he's gonna take it private
move number three okay and what this
guy's gonna that's gonna piss off a lot
of people okay he's gonna bring jack
back okay he's gonna bring jack back
jack dorsey because jack left because
it's just worse than working out with
the board everybody thought jack was the
bad guy jack didn't own 51 the company
when he left he only owned a couple
percent when he left he'll bring jack
back he will eliminate tom brady's
picture from the combine because that's
what he owes to him
and then he's gonna bring a guy back
that's gonna when he does that forget
about it
when he does when he brings back your
best friend he brings trump back which
he was a student of yours by the way we
got it we got i got great stories with
the trump sir wait wait time hold on no
you coach trump
no what do you say
you want me to get into that so he's
coming back on twitter so if trump comes
back and if if there's anybody that's
going to bring true trump back on
twitter it's going to be who it's going
to be it's going to be eli if he look at
that picture right there when uh when um
anyway so so so that story is official
wow and this guy if you would how
excited are you right now pat you know
what i'm excited about i'm excited about
the fact that people can officially go
out there and say stuff and not have to
worry about every other ward is going to
be uh taken out of context and they're
going to be taken down i think people
are free again but we're good
yeah good we're on the same page yeah so
you said you have a trump story tell us
i got a lot of them
anyways this was uh this was uh the late
90s and i had a girl who was uh number
one in florida in the 18th she was 14
years old and she was actually with img
which is a management company and the
father approached me about coaching her
and she modeled she and she sang also
and she was
good at both besides playing tennis and
he approached me about coaching her and
represented her because he didn't think
img took her modeling and singing
uh you know serious enough and they
wanted her to deliver the goods
and as a tennis player before we got
into the other stuff so he came to me
and i said i have an idea
and i knew
uh
trump had a management company called t
management so we set up i called the the
pro there and we went there he goes yeah
listen donald comes out every saturday
he goes through the uh by the spa he'll
come through the tennis say hi to
everybody then he goes and plays 18
holes so be out here practicing saturday
so we were there practicing on a
saturday i had monique this girl hitting
with a guy 180 in the world they're just
ripping ground strokes back and forth
now you gotta remember the trumpster
he's walking through there every day
he's probably seeing hamburgers and
cheeseburgers cl the the club players
and he's seeing this girl out there you
know who looks decent okay just crushing
ground strokes and he goes up to the the
pro they have there and starts talking
and he points down and so he comes down
to me he introduced himself
he goes who is that i got a box at the
u.s open their school looks really good
so i tell him the story blah blah blah
blah blah blah he goes listen anything i
can do
let me know so
he goes off two weeks later me and the
dad
fly to new york we meet with general
counsel okay
um we do the deal
for them to represent uh monique okay
i'm gonna run the tennis part okay
there's like 20 involved team management
gets 10 i get 10. so this was like the
middle of summer
then what happened so uh
we had a flight at six o'clock uh we go
into donald's office he goes you're
going back to florida i go yeah he goes
i want you to come back on the plane
with us okay i said no problem so we go
back early
great guy okay so we get on there
there's a lot of people going from new
york down to mar-a-lago for the weekend
uh donald's in there throwing potato
chips at people pretzels peanuts it's
like just the the nicest guy all right
he sat with me and there's a lot of
people on this flight
for two hours he got up now and then
talking about herschel walker new jersey
generals tennis football baseball
basketball i mean just such a
down-to-earth guy communicator okay a
very versatile guy
remember he's not president this was 19
this was 2 000. he was thinking about it
but he was doing that probably to get
some publicity so back then so
then he invites me to come to mar-a-lago
whenever we want so on and so forth so
now this is the best so now the u.s open
comes i'm going back and forth with nike
and fela i'm negotiating to get this
girl contract so listen to this this is
epic
midnight
hallway
on a napkin
okay i secure 1.8 million dollars
six hundred thousand dollars guaranteed
okay for a 14 year old girl to wear fila
clothing i do it on a napkin in the
hallway with general counsel he goes
rick you got it you got to come to trump
tower the next day and uh we'll tell
donald we did this deal so we go there
the next day
he goes uh bernie diamond was the guy
and he goes are we going to donald's
office
you it was amazing how rick it was doing
this whole thing and uh it was just
amazing he got one point eight million
dollars so i know that the trump sure is
already adding up
he goes listen i knew when i was at
mar-a-lago you were the best and you're
the best i said of course you called me
the best i just made you a hundred and
eighty thousand dollars well you're
really even the best now so so no so
listen he was uh just a down to earth
guy
and you know when he um
became president
that next because i went to bed that
night i didn't know what happened next
day i woke up
i put all 50 kids out there and i it's
on youtube i gave the speech of all time
you talk about forget rocky balboa
forget 69 mets forget venus walking off
the street and almost beat number one
this is the greatest upset
in the history of life this guy had
daggers knives bullets the media coming
every direction at him okay he doesn't
need this stuff he's taking he's mowing
down people left and right and the media
okay you gotta understand how mentally
strong it is forget the personality you
got to look at the character the drive
the persistence the inner qualities of
this guy forget all the nonsense if you
just look at how the guy is wired okay
you got to respect that okay and this is
listen i'm not a political guy at the
end of the day uh i i just love winners
are the rumors true that you're
considering being part of his cabinet in
2024 um if he asked me i wouldn't i'm
gonna be on the court
50 hours a week
craziness with the is that the whole
story you got another trump story or is
that the one that you got yeah
yeah yeah it's hard to beat that one you
got that's that's that's like
i like that i like that story you got
there by the way uh tennis-wise you said
carlos alcaraz is going to be the best
of all time
yeah and i was the flavor of the month
in spain after that quote listen i uh i
was actually at the miami open and i
went down there for the semis and finals
with uh
i was with christian rood the the best
player ever to come out of norway he got
to like 39 in the world where his son
casper
is now it's now like uh
five in the world or six in the world
yeah
norway yeah he's from norway we got a
big fan base in norway just so you know
okay so listen at the end of the day i
went down there we reunited i sat in a
box with them and i did get to see
casper play alcarez and i call him
alcatraz because he puts everybody in
prison okay so so
he i but i've seen him play before and i
already called it but all the nuances he
brings the athleticism
his hips turn faster people don't see
this than anybody i've seen he has a
drop shot from outer space that
he can just be just like it's sick but
he's a showman he loves crowds he was
born for this he's steady cut from the
same cloth as nadal his serve still
needs a little work i'm going on the
record i mean i predict a lot of things
i think he'll go down barring injury the
greatest player of all time
how old is it now
i said this with federer when he was 19.
i said this with pete too sam purse okay
because i look at this thing very
different and i said i haven't told
people i think he'll be number one by
the end of the year how old is he right
now and he's 18. he's 18 was he ranked
in the world he's now entered the top
ten he's in the top number nine let me
ask he's never been done but wait one
more thing yeah he's so complete there's
no holes in his game but he eats
pressure for breakfast and he can move
uh he'll win the french open you're
gonna hear it right here he'll win the
french open double figures okay you know
i'm just telling you where this is gonna
go but he can play on all surfaces he's
gonna be more vulnerable when guys have
big serves like anybody no one's going
undefeated no one ever has in any sport
all i'm saying is it's a generational
player i've seen this movie for 30 years
and i said he's feder nadal and djokovic
wrapped in one okay he was born to do
this barring injury we're seeing
something that's so special i can't even
tell you interesting i'm looking at the
uh the top 10 rankings here please
explain why no american is in the top 10
and i feel like no american men's tennis
player has been a top tenant for like a
decade plus what's going on in america
do you think i've been asked that
question before yeah i mean you're an
american tennis coach yeah what's going
on with america okay well the last guy
the last of mohicans was andy roddy
right he wasn't even as good as any of
the guys that were talking about federer
nadal djokovic he wasn't even as good as
sampras agassi nothing no you're right
about that but i feel andy overachieved
he won one grand slam could have won two
if he doesn't miss that high back emboli
against federer wimbledon but at the end
of the day um here's what happens
the great
athletes i don't mean good there's a lot
of good athletes very good friends with
francis tiafoe riley oppelpko who i
coached a little bit at 10 12 and 13. uh
taylor fritz is not bad there's a
difference between great
and good great is rare air we're all
good all of us in this room you know
it's it's a different fraternity and i
tell people all the time if i'd had
lebron
okay at age 10 mail it in number one
tennis player in the world okay the guy
would have served a buck 50 he'd have
been lightning in a bottle ferocious
competitor the best athletes go to
football baseball and basketball it's
easy to grab a ball and shoot a jumper
it's easy to go outside and tackle your
neighbor okay you don't tennis is
expensive and so the best athletes in
other countries i mean look at medvedev
the guys like gumby on steroids so a six
six and the guy moves and his tentacles
everywhere djokovic has made a rubber
you know they get better athletes we get
good athletes
okay and i'm just saying our best
athletes end up playing basketball
football baseball you're saying yeah and
then there's the mental part how you're
brought up your environment has a lot to
do with it remember
i called venus and serena what i saw
under the hood
i didn't see it on the outside if i
based on the outside i would have taken
a cab to the airport and left compton i
mean i based it on the inside okay i
knew what i could do technically and
this is what happens and i've talked to
the usta about this they they don't want
to look for the needle in the haystack
what i would do to answer your question
five six seven eight year olds yes that
young okay did their parents play the
olympics nba nfl okay you get the
genetic base so you got a few things
covered running jumping better maybe
environment quarter might have that okay
quarter the he might win a few grand
slams he'd be the one american i think
that could do that um
so
you got these bases covered running
jumping competing and then
biomechanically you get them with
someone like a rick macy who can get
your serve not just 140 but it's going
to go in and you got a certain forehand
like fetter and a backhand like joker so
you put there's no weaknesses but you
put them on a great athlete but you get
these kids young you do running jumping
you draw blood like they do in the
olympics you can test for all this stuff
and you got to fund it you got to put
money into the
money like i'm always watching like nick
i'm like i'm going all in with this i'm
not going to
how do you make your money on the back
end is it like boxing with a you know
training is like five percent or is it
like ufc where the you know quarterman
gets ten percent what's the business
model for you
because nick
nick was done broke he had no money at
the end of the documentary you're
watching it the guy's got nothing to his
name lost everything and he gave his
life to these oh you didn't see that the
guy ended he didn't have any money i
think the way it ended
what's the organ was the tennis
courts in umg or something like that
img they got all his stuff they got all
his land they got everything that he
owned they took from him because he had
nothing left and they specifically
changed the name to not have nick's name
volunteer anywhere they didn't want nick
voluntary's name damn anywhere so what
is the business model for a nick or rick
to make money okay well there's let's go
back a little bit there's a back story
nick got seven million dollars when img
took over
his thing but he might have been seven
million in debt i don't have a lot of
money i don't know i don't know that
whole thing so they took that blueprint
and they made it into something football
baseball basketball they turn it into
something that's just epic but
eliminated everything having to do with
his name yeah like almost like this is
non-existent here's the founder of the
organization and there's nothing about
him and img is massive right now 85
grand a year i don't know what the
number is but it's a pretty big number
yeah so so but dance your question uh
the the situation with the williams was
different because i had to fund the
project besides sweat equity you know
when you say
do guys get it on the back end you're
right they might get it on the back end
and not get paid you know they're a lot
of these peep coaches they might do
something for osaka or someone and they
don't even have a contract and sometimes
it's sometimes it's not enforceable
because of a minor and the parent it
becomes tricky you know with some of
these contracts
but i don't get into these type things i
only did that with venus and serena well
if you want me to if you want me to
coach you okay i do a private for 800 an
hour you know it's a very different
thing i don't do it for like free if you
want to leave it's it's a it's a
business i don't do it i don't care if
they leave you at this point you're
making 800 bucks an hour yeah it's a
straight but with venus and serena
that was different okay that was a whole
different thing did you make money on
the back end uh yeah we worked it all
out i don't want to get into the
minerals i don't want the details i just
want to know money was made on the back
end absolutely um you know
but that was a very different thing
and i haven't done it since and you
could imagine
even after the movie i've probably been
asked to do it over a thousand times
because i'm my kids better than venus
and serena yeah i don't know i don't
know about me
you know like sitting there saying okay
you put all this down all this and also
i guess you go sign the contract with
this person that person this person next
like left out and hey what happened to
all those years now you know you're
asked out now now what happened this guy
and you know credit's not given and
anyways i'm sure if you read the letter
that agassi wrote to him at the end it's
a pretty painful letter that he wrote to
him
about the ending of
the story agassi's family is related to
me i'm armenian assyrian so he lives in
vegas susan all those people that go
into unlv but anyways going back to this
uh you know a topic of you said
something earlier you said i don't have
time to you know i only want the best i
only want the best i only want the best
okay fine
um
how do you react
when you see a ben simmons oh
i strained my back in the game yesterday
oh but the phillies still have to pay me
the 76ers still have to pay me 20
million bucks
oh you know uh
simone biles oh this is too much
pressure you guys don't know how much
pressure it is i know i'm sure there's a
lot of pressure from everybody oh you
know naomi osaka somebody said you suck
can i get the mic and say something i
thought that was very weird to have
something like that happen
you know how do you handle
you know everything that these kids are
going through and now they're becoming
adults with social media with all of
that
yet you
said the dr lore
however you print the letter however you
pronounce his name he wrote those
engagements something about engagement
full engagement
everything's about mental toughness
everything's about emotional toughness
everything's about that everything how
do you manage what these kids and
athletes are saying nowadays it's too
much anxiety for me to play sports how
do you manage that yeah well first off
one of the things i i try to teach
everybody having the ability to forget
is more important than remember probably
not just sports but life yeah i mean
some people are still mad about stuff 20
years later and that's a skill you got
to have the ability to flip things in
your mind and take a negative and turn
it into a positive and it's hard because
everything's black and white like you
said with social media everybody is more
sensitive to to all this stuff but at
the end of the day with simmons and
biles and
naomi since i don't really
know them and how they're wired i'm just
looking from the outside you know it's
ironic because
it's easy maybe to take that approach
because they're still all making a lot
of money
you know asaka is getting 50 million
dollars a year
you know
simmons is making all this money same
with biles so
i don't really know them but looking
from the outside it's it's a bad look
for anybody you got to toughen up you
know that's what people are going to say
but i don't really
like to comment on that because i don't
know them if you ask me about someone
else and i knew them i could tell you
exactly what the temperature was and why
that is going on well let me ask you
this you're when you
uh uh coached the folks that you coach
okay capria all the names that you just
said right there you coach radical those
guys
uh how did how would you have handled it
if one of them or maybe did you ever
have a player that came up that
constantly was like mental and emotional
anxiety all of that
and you just eventually said look the
pros just name i may not be for you you
know you may want to go to a different
job because this comes with a lot of
pressure how did you handle that when
that came up when you were coaching them
well that does come up in the juniors
because people get nervous i've never
had anybody like at the mountaintop say
that like some of these people that
you've discussed i mean that's a whole
that's a whole different deal when
they've had all that success and money
and they've went through the process and
they've learned how to win and lose and
they've won grand slams it's a little
different but we don't know what's going
on in their personal life there could be
just a lot of other stuff that's going
on so
once again i gotta i would talk to them
okay that this comes with the territory
if you want to be great this is what
it's all about you know having the
ability to
forget you you it's a skill okay if
you're going to react to everything
you might nibble near the top you're
going to stay there because greatness
can stay there because they're
consistent mentally so unless i knew
exactly um a perfect example is roddy
you know he was so
mentally strong i knew his forehand was
going to be nuclear and the serve that i
helped him achieve was going to be super
sonic but he was just a dog you know he
was bulletproof i loved watching him
playing i interviewed him five six years
ago oh erotica yeah i had radical
valuetainment this guy
man he was exciting to watch you know he
had limitation but at the end of the day
he had the best quote of everything when
he started making all this money he goes
listen
everything else around me has changed
but it's still me and you and the court
i'm going to kick your butt mm-hmm
i gotta actually i don't wanna say push
back on you but i gotta follow up yeah i
know you said you you know you don't
really work or you're kind of from a
distance with the ben simmons of the
world and the simone biles but naomi
osaka is a tennis player a female tennis
player you've coached dozens if not
hundreds of female tennis players you
coach serena and venus williams hello
she made her name beating serena i
believe right and she cried and she won
you know i don't remember what
tournament it was but that's u.s open
she was a big winner yeah and then now
this past year she's had her issues
i mean if you can kind of get into the
mind of her because i believe you
probably do know her better than any
other you know
under the players that we mentioned
but if you were her coach or if you were
advising the coach what specific things
would you do because you do have
experience with this exact type of
person
yeah no you know
like i said there has to be a lot of
stuff
off the court because your life has
changed
when you go from maybe having not a lot
to be the richest female athlete
on the planet
okay and you know she's
in japan she's this iconic so
is either in or out i to me i'm black
and white about this stuff you you got
to be
so mentally strong if you're going to be
in you're in if you're out you're out
you you can't be half in and you can
kind of see that in her performance
she's
not all there because if you don't want
to die
to win every point you're going to lose
against better players i mean that's
what people don't see they might say oh
my kid has a better server forehand they
don't know what's under the hood and her
mental toughness was her strength and
now that she's
being sensitive and stuff like that i
would have a very different conversation
uh with her i don't know if i'd want to
coach her
if a player responded like that unless i
had more information then i'd have a
little better feel let me ask the
question a different way because i know
what you're you're you're you're walking
you know you're in the business so you
can't really give the answer on a mic
that you you know
anyway so i understand i respect that
but let me ask a question a different
way
when you were coaching in the 80s 90s
you've you've coached in five different
decades no am i saying it correctly or
six to four decades five different
decades right yep okay so
how much was this the topic of
discussion in the 80s 90s 2000
amazing question
never
okay that's the question that's what
you're saying no that's never a question
never yeah never a while you're saying
mental toughness or what anxiety
depression i'm like oh my god i can't
handle this no you know it's it's
because it's a real thing these days no
no no no no no no they're making it a
real yeah that's what you're saying
no it's it's the social media it's
entitlement kids are brought up
different you know there's you know kids
are a little more spoiled you know
things are easier you know it's it's
it's just different even physical
fitness different kids got in shape by
just running around outside playing tag
now you got trainer it's a it's a
different world and it's create uh
created a lot of marshmallows mentally
you know what i'm saying and so but
that's that's the question right there
this never ever came up to the point
where you even kind of felt it let alone
would express it like that i mean so
that means it's very deep so how can
kids be kids be mentally tougher it
sounds like you agree with exactly what
pat where pat was going i agree exactly
how do you keep your kids your coaching
these days let me ask you a different
question let me ask a different question
let me ask a different question
you're the expert we're just amateurs
here we're not in the world we're in a
completely different world we're in okay
how much of
this
is a
problem
that was non-existent that's been
created purely out of the
you know out of the imagination of you
know how they say
all these new uh uh
uh for what's what's the uh phobics that
we have afraid of this afraid of that
afraid of this whatever and then you
need these new medicines you need this
new this new this big farmer's making
all this money based on different fears
that they're making and all these
medicines that people are taking is
based on all these phobias that was
created by these scientists who
represent these big farmers again these
are stories we've all read about how
much of it is just fabricated that's got
these kids believing i really have this
issue
yeah a lot of it okay you know what i
mean because it's like everybody wants a
quick fix okay
uh to
to get anywhere you got to take the
stairs not the escalator you know what i
mean it's everybody wants a quick fix on
everything
um but no you're you're right this this
never existed but i need to dive in
about the family component
a lot of this also
is
the mom and dad okay because
not that they have total control over it
but they are raising kids
they are raising kids some just throw
them out there and let them grow like
grass other water it and fertilize it
yeah you know so the parents you know
they want their kid to be rough and
tough and you know be competitive and
take a punch and then they go the ball
and buy them a gucci bag so you know
it's just a bizarre
thing
that it's a lot of it is
the parent you know and i'll go back to
where i started you know this interview
richard
richard williams what i saw
at nine and ten okay which other people
didn't it wasn't on the outside outside
was a train wreck
sorry venus serena it was a train by
where he told him that it was a train
wreck on the outside but on the inside
i never saw it so that box was checked
and a few others because i knew
i knew
that's the wild card you don't know how
people are going to freak out under
pressure a quarterback when some guy
wants to knock him out yeah you know
when the game's on you don't know that
and i saw
they the minute i changed the game to
like competitive
it it kind of freaked me out and i've
never been freaked out about anything so
but that was done
at a young age and that's probably why
richard williams was just saying all
this insanity
uh because he saw the same thing but it
took someone that had that eye because
on the outside you can't see it so so
um
the uh sport stats okay let's go through
some of those okay
you got
tiger's dad okay
you got
uh lavar ball
you got uh uh the manning's father who's
got two bars two archie man who's got
two boys with two super bowls each which
is insane right yep you got king richard
you got emmanuel agassi you got a lot of
these stories right mj's dad mj's dad
yeah but you know okay fine you can put
mj's that there as well
all these stories with these dads so
then the question becomes the foul one
you know how when i talk to investors i
say what's most important the
entrepreneur
the talent and the entrepreneurs the
team the idea the technology what's most
important right or you'll ask hey uh
tom uh penn who was a gm for the field
f76 i think he was gm and then he went
to espn so what's most important
ownership team a great coach a superstar
player or a great gm right you ask these
questions okay
in these specific examples williams okay
agassi you know manning's all this stuff
who
gets the bigger percentage of success
okay and i know that's the last thing
you want to be pressured to talk about
because i think what percentage is
parents
what percentage is
no it's it's to me the biggest
percentage is always the parents you got
to remember this is a genuine degree
how big of a percentage by the way
it could be well over 75
this is the genetics listen the genetics
i'll say it again
i've never had anybody come to me and
the the parent did nothing and the other
parent did nothing and the kid became a
world-class athlete
i've just never seen it in my sport
there's some can you repeat that folks
if you guys so some people ask me and
they say why do you bring somebody who's
a tennis coach we never talk tennis here
i'm a parent
and i only bring people here to my show
that i'm interested in not you're
interested in this is called the pbd
podcast because i
want to learn on how to become a full
complete package better human being and
a leader okay
listen to what he just said i judge
myself kind of like people ask me oh my
god pat you're so impressed i'm like
dude you don't know my dad
you you give me way too much credit
my dad raised the damn standards on work
ethic and if you say you're gonna do
something you do it and honesty and all
this stuff i get way too much credit you
should give more credit to my dad eighty
percent the credit should be to my debt
on how he raised me the how he
challenged me how it was never enough it
was so freaking annoying sometimes yeah
right and then you and obviously dad and
mom mom played a different role role as
well
but it's such a important dynamic on
what you just said can you repeat that
sentence one more time you've never seen
a
no i've never seen someone become a
world-class player okay in in my sport
that the mom or dad didn't do something
in sports you know with the genetics
like whether they played high level
college or high school or maybe the
family tree it could be a grandfather
who was an olympic sprinter or you know
a russian who was a a swimmer so there
has to be something i've never seen it
ever okay but you're saying physically
genetics are you also saying how they
know interact with their child
physically now the mental part okay uh
because remember if they're with rick
macy or whoever they're with me x amount
of time a day the rest of time when you
go home and close that door you're with
family
you don't know what's percolating you
don't know what life lessons are going
into that kid's head how they're how
they're wired you know it's it's it's
major league to me it's the most
important that's why once again you
asked me about american tennis and
listen i'm not throwing a net out there
over the whole country or everybody
you're always going to have those flyers
but at the end of the day the eastern
europeans you got people they're rougher
they're tougher it's like when i saw
serena she was like a little pit bull
once she got a hold of you she wasn't
gonna let go and i just said i gotta get
this kid's strokes in a serve and so
that's that's you know and that's half
the battle how you're gonna handle you
know and and
how you're gonna compete and you can
teach that and nurture it and i do that
yeah but it's hard to rewire things that
have been put in these kids head so so
you know how uh uh uh
the the story of uh what's that one
movie with russell crowe the beautiful
mind where you're going to that one
place that he has and it's got all these
formulas like what the hell is in this
guy's mind what does he think about it
or even greg kating who found who killed
tupac and big and he's got this whole
report of names there in even the
american gangster where there's this one
scene where it's like who is the drug
dealer behind everything and you know
it's denzel washington
it's
typically when you see like somebody
you know performing at a high level
somebody in that lineage raised the
standards was tough was a son of a [ __ ]
was difficult was challenging nothing
was ever enough and papa like when
agassi tells a story with my dad nothing
was ever enough i don't know if you know
his story is a different story as well
it's almost like yeah buddy but you
would have never married graff if that
wasn't your dad
you would have never met her you would
have never been a champion if it would
if i was i totally get it frustrating
totally get it i get that fully
understand it but there
it's almost like you know mike mike
talked about in the last dance where he
says when you're going through it
it's so difficult
when my dad was pre this is what my
michael says in the last dance do you
remember that one scene when he says you
know hey michael why don't you go play
outside do you know what you know yeah
you're just not let me and your brother
do what they're doing he says in that
moment it drove me it was so difficult
to go through it
but he made it through and look what
level of a champion he became it becomes
mentally and emotionally tough to be
able to handle all this pressure so i
don't know i think the part that you
talk about that people are raising more
soft
people today and parents is like oh my
gosh you're okay oh my gosh you're okay
oh my gosh you're okay i don't know a
lot of oh my gosh you're okay growing up
uh you know as a kid so listen some
people today will call that terrible
parenting rick how dare you say such a
thing
you're not empathetic
you're not compassionate you don't
understand what it is you know so all
the stuff that you talk about but the
the the percentage of making it to the
top level take elon musk's that away
and his dad doesn't say what he says to
him does he must become who he is today
i don't know about it do you have
another tiger woods ever tiger woods won
the 2007 u.s open with a broken knee
unbelievable that's a rare specimen
right there with his dad did you watch
his documentary well and yeah and he
said phil mickelson is a better player
than he is right but he didn't have the
worth work ethic that that earl woods
instilled in tiger woods that killer
instinct did you watch the documentary
parts of it have you watched your
documentary like half of it i dude i
highly recommend you watch the whole
thing did you did you get it i did not
i'm telling you guys i so here's the
mistake i made one night i started
watching at 10 30 and it's three hours i
said i'm gonna watch it today and i'm
gonna finish the next three nights i
stay up to two o'clock in the morning i
watch part one and part two it's that
ridiculous that's why i'm a big fan of
tiger i mean even all the stuff that he
has i'm just a fan of tiger i'm a fan of
people that are willing to tolerate that
much pain
it is so difficult to become a williams
yeah it is so difficult to win at that
level well pat let me ask you because
you started the conversation or this
question with you know are kids
conditioned these days on the phobia
these days and and obviously you
transitioned to you wouldn't be who you
were without
your dad zero right and he's a coach god
would have chosen somebody else as my
dad you don't know who i am my question
to you is then pat as a father you told
a story a couple podcasts ago about you
went up to i think dylan's coach and
you're like no you could be hard on him
that's fine you know you told that story
yeah
you know but you're seeing what kids are
dealing with these days everything that
rick just said about social media and
you know the phobias
how are you taking this information and
becoming a better dad to your kids in
today's generation
so he made a very good point in sales i
made a mistake early on of driving
everybody the same way because i drove
this one guy this one way and it worked
with them i said this is going to work
with everybody he hated it she couldn't
handle it he quit like what happened how
come you can't be like this person well
they're different personalities can't
drive everybody the same way right one
is more encouragement the other one
needs to say well i think that guys uh
woke up an hour before you made 100 more
calls than you that worked with him but
it discouraged this one then the other
one was good with the selfish desires he
wants the big house the accolades the
fame all that stuff but this other one
could give a [ __ ] about all that stuff
this one wants to do it for mom and dad
to make them proud that other person
loves america and his country he wants
to do something to give back to the
country that gave his freedom and this
other guy from el salvador he loves his
country but he came here he can't stand
the fact that what happened to el
salvador he wants to make money the one
they go back and be in office in el
salvador that person is driven in a
different way so not everybody is driven
the same way so with my kids i asked
them a question earlier about different
ways of coaching like what your kids
need
at the when they're younger it's just
for them to love the game
then the next phase is what your kids
need at this age is more fundamentals
right like learning like you know
perfect practice makes perfect not
practice makes perfect they have to add
the perfect practice makes perfect okay
so now they need to learn the
fundamentals the right way like i'm not
teaching tico i throw the ball i'm the
wrong guy to teach you how to throw the
ball you can teach them how to throw the
ball better than i can teach them how to
throw the ball right because you're an
athlete i was not right so now it's
getting the fundamental people around
them and to also like the game a little
bit of competition a little bit of
pressure then the real pressure's
showing up when you're getting at the 10
to 14 age you kind of seen a little bit
can they handle it or not you need a
little bit more support all this stuff
to watch them i don't know i just
watched to see we're all different
and with the kids yesterday we're
playing baseball outside dylan wants to
go
45 more minutes let me hit five more
balls
let me hit five more balls let me find
that no no that wasn't long enough fine
i'm like at this point i'm we missed
church we missed church yesterday
because of dylan well i'm disappointed
so i'm like five more balls i know i
missed you at the you would you want you
want that passion i mean that's gold
right there you don't you're not pushing
that's from within my oldest but my
oldest said daddy i want to go inside
and draw uh more uh movie characters see
you later but the point is his you later
is hollywood and movies storytelling
it's not baseball so i'm trying to as a
parent like your daughters they don't
want to play tennis but they crush it in
gymnastics
it's that
you not getting in the way of what is
their strength
and yet still having to teach them
mental and emotional toughness no matter
what game they play so my son's like yes
i don't like baseball why don't you like
baseball he had one very bad moment in
baseball that's private between him and
i
and uh like so i whispered to him i said
come here is that why and he kind of
looks away so that's why isn't it
because at one moment yeah
so that's between you and i she says but
i don't like baseball i said do you not
like baseball do you not like it because
it links to a painful moment i said what
are you going to do when you make a
movie one day and everybody says it's a
terrible movie how are you going to
handle that good point what are you
going to do you think this thing is a
baseball thing this is a live thing baby
this is everything we do we do podcasts
it's just the shittiest podcast ever
than the next podcast just the best
podcast ever than the next podcast you
guys suck two podcasts later just the
greatest they're gonna be the biggest it
like it's such a bipolar thing that you
gotta be able to manage it no you gotta
have it you gotta be able to
more than anything psychiatrists not
coaches right yeah psychologists
psychologists yeah but let me let me
just go back to something you said
earlier about
the the coaching parks i think this is
important okay i can have a kid who's
dead tired okay and they they can't go
anymore and i might say okay we're gonna
do
a 20 ball suicide where i just run them
side to side okay and they get to 18 and
they just can't go anymore and all
sudden
i say
twenty dollars you get this ball
and let me tell you something there's
turbo
inside the kid
that i've never seen before or if i say
i'll give you a hoodie
like the one i have on or
uh you get a gatorade or i'll give you
five bucks or water capitalism okay
here's what happens when there's grades
or there's rewards i don't care how
tired you are you could be throwing up
okay i always have the quote one more
one more
as in wn okay
and
this is what i do with everybody okay i
get them to push boundaries
their limits not limit their challenges
and so it's amazing the water ball if i
say water ball okay out of nowhere
you got like uson bolt you know you just
got this lightning the kids like dragon
whatever because the mind controls the
body okay and you know i talked to them
about navy seals i talked to them about
all these type things and i give
situations when i say
waterball
all the parents like they just laugh
because 98 of the kids all sudden it's
like
they just run like you have no idea
where before they're letting the mind
control the body or
if i put kids together
and we they could be dead tired and we
play tag
in an area
okay all sudden they're not tired
anymore they're shaking and bacon
they're juking they're bobbing they're
weaving they're running all over the
place even though they're dead tired
because of one word
fun
when it's fun
okay
you are not tired anymore whether it's
business whether i'm just telling and
this is how it comes across in the movie
so do i do things differently i feel the
temperature okay and i react accordingly
because i keep balls and strikes on
every lessons you got to get better or
you're getting worse
last uh what's your opinion on nick's
style of leadership
nick boleteri
nick and i are pretty good friends you
know we go way back um
it's it's a very different situation
with nick early on he was the first to
meet mohicans he put that thing together
in bradenton he was the first one to
really do an academy where he got guys
together he just figured put them
together combat and you know put people
together that were living in new york or
wisconsin or michigan bring them to
florida battle it out
and you'll get better
nick was a great motivator
he'd give you the shirt off his back
okay then when it became i think
technically or biomechanically he was
always very limited
not because he wasn't a good player or
anything
but when it becomes easy and then img
gets involved you don't really continue
your education but he had that img
machine you know pumping volatility's
name out for 30 years okay but what nick
has done for
uh the game of tennis um
and the academy business i think is
amazing but i
i very seldom have been on a court with
him just like if someone would ask well
how does rick macy coach what they
should do
get on the court with me i'll be there
on six tomorrow morning and they can
hang with me for six hours and they'll
have a different
understanding than what they see on
instagram
of youtube even though i got the top
selling videos in the country okay they
there's a lot of meat on the bone i help
a lot of people for free but once live
and in color and you can interact and
you can see all the subtle nuances of
how things are done why to say it when
to say it how to say it
there's a whole art to this and and
that's coaching and so when you went to
saban in the dolphins sure you need the
goods or you need the thoroughbred to
win the derby but also you got to relate
you got to know how to relate to people
and that's what great coaches do so it
doesn't matter who's on the other side
of the net uh i can get them to do more
than what they ever thought they could
do i love that by the way did you see
the recent story of uh and we'll do this
last one and wrap up is joycovich
uh uh uh is that the one or no novak
joker novak djokovic slams wimbledon ban
on russian tennis players as crazy and
says political politics should be out of
uh sports uh let me read this story
uh it says parallels between the ukraine
war and the kosovo war in the late 90s
which took place when he was a child he
said i will always
condemn war i will never support war uh
being myself a child of war i know how
much emotional trauma it leaves in
serbia we all know what happened in 1999
and the balkans we have had many wars in
recent history however i cannot support
the decision of wimbledon i think it's
crazy when politic interferes with
sports the result is not good what do
you think about what he said i totally
agree with the joker he'll probably go
down uh until alpharez catches fire
alcatraz yeah um as the greatest player
ever to hold a tennis racket when it's
all said and done because he has a lot
left in the tank but i totally agree
with him um
that shouldn't have anything to do with
it you know it has nothing to do with it
um wimbledon's always been a little
different
if anything they should give you know
the 30 million dollars they got from an
insurance policy they had for the
pandemic by the way you probably didn't
know that they got 30 million when they
didn't do wimbledon from because they
had it in the class if there was a
pandemic they get 30 mil and they didn't
have the tournament and they got 30 mil
that year who did wimbledon they had an
insurance policy back in the early 2000s
is this public info yeah you know so
they have 30 million from who exactly
the insurance company if they had to
cancel it because of a pandemic which
who would put that in an insurance the
day you think that you have a pandemic
it's not gonna happen that's actually
great planning by wimbledon great
planning but what i'm saying they should
give some cheddar to ukraine instead of
banning russian tennis players i think i
agree with the joker i think it's like
insane and it's unfortunate um
because holy [ __ ] do you know what the
actual number is 141 million dollars
look at that right there
yeah forbes wimbledon's organizers set
for 141 million dollar payout
after taking out pandemic insurance you
know what the premium is per year you
know what the premiums per year probably
two million dollars per year look at
that two million dollars per year
got him a hundred and
million wimbledon was rooting for a
pandemic
yeah they were okay with the leader in
the clubhouse the pandemic but i agree
with the joker i just feel it's
unfortunate i hope other uh tournaments
don't do the same thing because the
players i mean tennis is a tough sport
you got to pay your own expenses it's
global it's not like nba their stuff's
not guaranteed it's very expensive and i
think to deprive them of that
opportunity is unfortunate well listen
uh i i hope the audience has enjoyed
this as much as i've enjoyed it yeah
this was awesome i'm so great we were
able to do this rick uh you're a
qualified badass i'm so glad we had you
on and not only that but you're a cool
sport great sport telling cool stories
uh learn a lot a lot listening to you
got two more you got two more minutes i
guess serena's story tell me okay the
people people love this i told this and
it went viral okay we're on the court
serena is 11 years old it's july okay
110 degrees a lizard can't even go
across the court without getting cooked
okay
so it's and venus is on one court
serena's on another always side by side
and
i told serena you got to move your feet
and she looks at me and you know that
look you've seen it at the u.s open she
goes why i said you say you want to be
number one she go now she's 11. okay
she goes i will be number one i said
how'd i get you to move your feet she
goes rick
i'm really hungry can you have scott go
to the snack machine i want some hot
curly fries a snickers bar a pepsi and
on the way to work today daddy drove by
a stand and they were selling green day
t-shirts can you have scott get a green
day t-shirt and i said wait a minute if
i get you the snickers bar the curly
fries the pepsi scott gets the green day
t-shirt will you move your feet shows
rick you see that tall skinny girl over
there she's pointing to venus because
venus was like that i'll make her look
slower than molasses so i go scott go
the snack machine get the hot curly
fries snickers bar the pepsi tomorrow on
the way to work on linton boulevard
get the green day t-shirt so he brings
all the goodies serena goes under the
canopy has her snack goes back on the
court
for one hour straight she's sitting
cross-court and down the line with a guy
like 450 in the world they had hitting
partners
sweats pouring off this little girl like
niagara falls no water break an hour
straight just going berserk one hour
straight i'm on the other court now with
uh venus she goes hey rick it's 3 15.
i'm done and you better have that green
day t-shirt here in the morning
because you gotta remember she's she's a
mother now and when i told her some of
these stories at the after party she's
literally crying okay on the ground
because she can relate i mean she wasn't
as mature as venus that's why she turn
pro at 16 and venus 14 but that's a
great serena story but at the end of the
day like you asked me earlier about
coaching
she was in the tank she's already played
four hours
and i got the best out of her i won she
won
richard won and the rest is history i
love that and the power of green day
baby there you go green day
power of i read a book called parental
capacity and it said if you want to win
at the highest level for your kids if
you want your kids to win at the highest
level you need the right supporting cast
around you coaches teachers professors
tutors
uncles you need the right people around
that keep challenging and lifting your
kids up the right ones can help that kid
become somebody and obviously you played
a very very big role in what these
williams sisters did
and uh it's great to be part of history
it's great to have a movie be done and a
guy like john bernthal one of my
favorite actors play you that's like a
dream come true man it's exciting stuff
there to
have you on so having said that tomorrow
we have we have a
diamond dallas page tomorrow and then
thursday we have paul manafort that
should be very interesting right there
what that's going to be like having said
that brother was great having you on
rick thank you thank you for having me
yes
i may take a lesson with you man and see
what you got with this
one i say we do it we recorded it
hilarious but wait a minute we'll do it
and we'll video and i'll let you know
where you're at technically genetically
strategically and maybe at the end i
might say we have to take up golf but
i don't know you got a deal i say we do
it
thank you everybody bye-bye bye bye bye
you